so let's talk a little bit about
something that frankly I do not like to
talk about and I don't think most people
like to talk about and that's the notion
of becoming very ill and dying and then
what happens to everyone that you leave
behind and to understand why this is an
important scenario let's imagine and
I'll just put myself in this scenario
hopefully this does not happen let's
imagine a scenario where something like
that happened to me and or my wife
without us doing any type of planning
any type of end of life planning any
type of estate planning you'd have a
situation where let's say heaven forbid
we got into a car accident and we are
not in a position to make decisions on
should we be put on life support forever
should we should some experimental
procedure be done if we haven't given a
health care proxy and that's someone
that you put in writing usually someone
like a partner or a family member or
child that can make a decision for you
in the event that you can't make the
decision for yourself if we have not
done that if we have ever not given a
health care proxy that is going to be
somewhat arbitrary what's going to
happen to us in that situation and it
might not happen in a way that's good
for us or along in line with our wishes
or in line with our family's wishes but
let's say that that plays out and then
we die at let's say I die and let's say
my wife isn't there this is really a
morbid situation but if I do no estate
planning then all of the things that I
own are then going to go into a court
process known as probate and probate is
where the court tries to figure out well
okay Sal had all of this stuff this is
his estate and his estate is both the
things that he has but also the things
that he owes I might have assets but I
might owe money on a mortgage I might
have a car loan I might have credit card
debt so the court in the probate process
tries to figure out okay who's going to
get the assets and who's going to be
able to cover all of these these
liabilities all of this debt that might
be owned uh and it can be a long process
in the in the interim in which my
children
or other folks that I care about that
ideally I would have liked to have
access to those assets don't have access
to it and sometimes it can be a little
bit arbitrary because it's going to be
decided by a court instead of me
deciding ahead of time
and then just adding to that if I
haven't or my wife hasn't Whoever has
passed away hasn't specified what
happens to your children if you have
children who are still children who's
going to take care of them if you
haven't thought about that and specified
it then the court might decide just the
nearest relative who may or may not want
to take care of your kids and that might
be again a sub-optimal situation
so in general it's a good idea
especially once I would say you have
real people depending on you probably
once you start to have a family for
someone to do end-of-life planning
estate planning now some of you might
think I'm a kid I don't need to do this
well you could also talk to your parents
about doing this so that that type of
scenario does not play out in your own
life and so it's important to sit
healthcare proxy someone that you think
understands what you want to happen or
has values similar to yours to be your
proxy in a situation that you can't
decide for yourself it's important at
minimum to have a will a will will tell
probate hey these are my wishes I would
like
um my children to get my my my stocks
equally or that one kid who didn't do it
didn't didn't
um has been rebellious maybe they get a
little bit less I I don't Advocate that
type of thing but
um at least it becomes clearer so that
when it goes through probate it's going
to happen now there's ways that you can
actually really make things happen much
quicker than even going through that
probate process and that's putting
assets into something called a trust a
trust is an entity that assets can be
put into and essentially it's an entity
that takes care that that uses those
assets especially once you're gone or if
you're not in a position to manage them
yourself to then divvy it up amongst
other folks so I can tell you that my my
family we have created we have put our
assets or not all of them but a lot of
them the ones the most important ones
into a trust so that if worst case
myself and my wife die
immediately our children will have
access to the assets and be able to
manage the estate so to speak and and so
generally speaking it's very important
to do this planning ahead of time
there's other words that you're going to
hear when you hear about estate planning
beneficiary well that's the people who
will benefit those are the people who
are likely to these are the people who
are going to get the assets you're going
to hear words like uh guardianship of
minor children Guardian a guardian is a
person who takes care of children who
are not adults yet but the very
important thing to consider if you are
an adult now especially with people
depending on you is to do this planning
and if you are not an adult maybe you
are in the care of other people they
might view it as a little bit
self-serving but it really is just
prudent encourage them to think about
these things because I don't think
anyone wants their loved ones to have to
struggle in these situations or just
because of a little lack of planning
have to end up in a very very
sub-optimal situation especially a time
where they're already probably going to
be dealing with things because you're an
amazing person and if you are gone
they're going to be very sad about that
and you don't want them to also have to
deal with the stress of dealing with
probate not having access to financial
resources having to live with family
members that neither you nor they want
to live with that can all be avoided
with a little bit of planning